hello everyone
and welcome to today's live broadcast
molecular diagnostic solutions and a
pandemic
planning for the 2020-2021 flu season
with implementation of the e-plex
respiratory pathogen panel 2.
i'm alexis crowles of labyrinth and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab roots and
sponsored by
genmark diagnostics for more information
about our sponsor
please visit their site at genmarkdx.com
now let's get started i would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as we want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click on the send button
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
i'd like to now introduce our presenter
dr hebba mustafa
assistant professor of pathology and the
director of molecular virology at
john hopkins medicine for a complete
biography honor presenter
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
dr mostafa you may now begin your
presentation
hi everyone um thank you so much for
this invitation
um so today i was invited to talk about
the gen mark um respiratory panel rp2
and its projected significance um um
in our workflow here at hopkins hospital
lab
and also our projected significance of
adding
surco v2 target to the diagnostic panels
in the middle of this pandemic we are
all experiencing
so this is my disclosure slide
and um this is the learning objective of
today
so i will discuss on the hopkins lab
response
uh to the source cov2 pandemic and
sorry and our current testing workflow
and also um i would like to discuss on
the expectations of the workflow during
the flu season
and how we could potentially benefit of
panels that can include the source cov2
targets
um so i will start with a little
background about the virus
and the pandemic sarco v2
belongs to a family of viruses which is
called coronaviridae
and this family of viruses characterized
by being enveloped so the particles are
enveloped
and the genome is a positive sense rna
and it's quite large a genome
between the other rna viruses it
actually ranges in size from
28 to 32 kilobases
and the name corona stems from the shape
with electron microscopy
um coronaviruses characterized by
those crown shaped projections that
appear by electron microscopy
um so hence corona means actually um
like a
crown um
so the family uh coronaviruses and
contains
a lot of animal and bird viruses um
and they could actually cause severe
disease and animals
and and um and birds uh however the
human coronal viruses that have been
identified so far are seven
um i highlighted them here in red um
those that belong to uh alpha and the
beta coronaviruses
on are mainly mammals
viruses and the human viruses belong
solely to alpha and beta coronaviruses
gamma and the delta coronaviruses are
basically
um viruses that um infect mammals
uh um sorry birds but also can infect
mammals
um the highly pathogenic coronaviruses
started with
um the very first to source coronavirus
in 2002 to 2003 in
china this outbreak was limited though
and it did not extend to a pandemic
and the new cases were noted since this
time
this was followed by nurse or the middle
east coronavirus in 2012
that is still actually circulating but
in a small scale and
in a limited geographical scale but
it has higher mortality between the
three highly
pathogenic coronaviruses then the third
one is the current
circle v2 which has caused this
devastating pandemic
that we are currently experiencing and
has been causing the disease which has
been known as covet 19.
um so this is the current situation
through hopkins dashboard which is our
dashboard we use for monitoring the
cases
you can see here this is the total
numbers of confirmed cases
um worldwide and as well as the coverage
related this
um this this is as of july 18th and you
can still see
here in the uh bottom right corner the
curve of the increase in cases
and it is actually still going up
unfortunately
um so the emergence of this new source
um i should say was not really
surprising because the studies that were
done
after the first source in 2003
indicated that all the genomic
requirements for making a new source
virus already exist
in bats and it is not really a matter of
f it's actually a matter of when
the virus is spread outside of china was
very quick for starsky v2
but implementing the molecular
diagnostics in the u.s
didn't start until february 4th
when the cdcsa was authorized
through the fda by emergency use
authorization
and then the outbreak
was handled in the u.s in february um in
a way
that didn't really um permit uh larger
scale diagnostics
nationwide and then
because of the limitation in diagnostic
testing
um the criteria for presumptive
diagnosis was mainly
based on the
based on the history of exposure to a
new
case or travel history to china
um and the um
the this this this really limited the
um the availability of large-scale
testing
and also um the capacities of testing
in the labs uh was was limited and
not a lot of information was available
to the physician back then
um the situation changed towards the end
of february
when the fda changed the rules and they
offered
um or allowed the diagnostic
laboratories to develop
their own assays and to apply for their
own eua
or emergency emergency use authorization
and now there is a long list of
molecular assays that have received eua
and largely they are excellent in their
specificity for sarco v2 testing
most of these assays are real-time pcr
methods
um and they target different regions
within the genome of the virus
um the cdc panel assay choose two
regions within the nucleocapsid gene n1
and n2
the whose test i choose to screen with
the e gene
and then follow this with a confirmation
with another gene
but in general most of the available
essays on
targets two genes two molecular targets
at least
which increases the sensitivity and the
specificity
so this is the genome of sarcicle v2 and
i highlighted here
the regions that are currently commonly
used and the available molecular methods
for diagnosis
you can see here the n-gene and e-gene
but also the
polymerase region and also the spy genes
are also used in some of the essays
sorry i didn't advance my slide
so here you can see the regions that are
currently commonly used um in the
molecular methods for diagnosis
so a lot of initial concerns um
when the molecular testing for surgical
v2 started
was around the clinical sensitivity of
of these
assays for diagnosis um after a few
months of testing
and after some research um we currently
now understand
that the timing of the specimen
collection in relation to the onset of
symptoms
and as well as the specimen types
collected
are very important in determining the
molecular result
um also we know that the performance is
usually dictated by
the agent's design not really by the
target
itself um and there might there might be
slight differences in the analytical
performance
um so you can see here
um for example that almost studied
studies
on so far indicate that the peak
of the viral load is usually within the
first
five to six days after the onset of
sentence
we also know now that some puzzling
scenarios um
uh exist like for example that are
prolonged shedding
of viral rna that can extend um to
weeks or even months after the diagnosis
you can see here those are three
different studies
uh that has shown that uh within uh five
to six days of the onset of sentence you
can see that uh this is when
uh higher viral loads are usually
detected and
this is both in the upper and lower
respirator retracted specimens
i should also highlight that those three
different studies
use the different diagnostic methods
that actually target
on different genes
so that has been now identified as a
critical
variable in determining the result for a
molecular method
and it is actually summarized here in
that very nice
figure that is showing how the vital rna
shedding uh peaks shortly after the
onset of sentence
also you can see that this is true for
both
upper and lower respiratory retracted
specimen types
and you can also see in through this
figure that on some reports
also showed that um even before the
start of sentence
the viral rna can be detected in some
cases
uh detection of the viral virus from um
stool um uh can also uh or
was also shown and it's highlighted in
this figure as well
so really pcr is likely positive um
earlier in the disease
and it's likely negative later in the
disease
the specimen type is also important um
variable um so the specimens that are
collected from the lower respiratory
tract
um which includes both bel
and sputum among others um those were
shown
through multiple studies
to maintain positivity for longer than
the positivity from the upper
respiratory specimens
and some papers also showed that they
might even have higher vital loads
but like now the the use of these
specimens um
is really restricted to a certain
population of patients
uh saliva is now like the the huge topic
um in surgical v2 diagnostics
uh it's used for diagnosis um as a
promising source
because it will it will assist um if we
face supply chain issues with
swaps and media and also it's a nice
specimen for self-collection so it will
be
better for larger scale diagnosis and
screening
and it has been shown now through this
through multiple papers
that um the virus can be detected in
saliva
the sensitivity appears lower than the
nasopharyngeal swabs though
um however
it's a cell it's a still a promising
source and some left distorted already
to offer saliva for testing
other sources also include sulfur
collected nasal swabs
also have been or are considered for
diagnosis
but so far that will be standard for
molecular diagnosis of surgical
v2 and for comparisons um has been the
nasopharyngeal swab
uh so now i will start talking about our
response
um at hopkins and uh what was our
uh response to this pandemic uh so in
the in the beginning of the pandemic
um as many other labs in the states we
were
quickly trying to validate um a method
for diagnosis
and we started with an assay
or agents that were provided by altoona
diagnostics
and this was our first essay which we
applied for an aua4 and we went live
with this essay on march 11th
uh but quickly then we realized um
that there is an urgent need for
building the redundancy and testing
for the agents supply chain and also to
try to build
our redundancy and the gene targets of
the
assays that we use also we needed some
assays
that can offer a quicker turnaround time
for certain population of patients
so we quickly validated additional
methods and also we brought in
different high throughput platforms so
by the end of march
we were actually running six different
essays
and currently we are running nine
different validated assays
um and um those assays that as you can
see here in this table
um they differ and the target genes they
differ in their throughput
and they differ also in their turnaround
time
and this is the volumes we have been
testing
on this is up to july 11th um so our
testing volumes
fluctuates but they keep currently
trending up
and uh we we
ran at an average of uh 652
but now we we test around 1500
per day um and our positivity rate um
uh those started to decline uh um
we we started to see it ramping up again
um
uh so now that we built this redundancy
and uh in testing platforms and testing
essays
uh it was very important for us to also
um
build um an algorithm um of ordering
uh it's also again because of the supply
chain
and the difference in um and the
capacity of the agents between different
um assays that can run as a stat versus
those that
can run batches uh so we built this
um algorithm of ordering through through
uh like
um a series of questions uh this was um
with help
from the id team and fiction prevention
epic and here in the lab
to help assign that is the priority um
and to determine which essays we will
run as a stat
or as an urgent through the step testing
of those we reserve for the eddy
uh labor and delivery and in certain
situations
and then we have an urgent category uh
where
we can uh still prioritize testing but
this will not be run
um on our stat platforms which are
mainly the gen expert and the acula
but the urgents will be batched and will
go to the
uh our uh um quicker platforms including
the e-plex
and the animodex and then everything
that can wait will be also batched and
run as a routine
although we have this criteria of
testing we were successful
in maintaining our turnaround the time
even for the routine testing
and an average of 11 hours for the stat
testing our turnaround
time has become now about two hours
and this is from specimen collection to
turning the result
so we did a good job in um in our
testing algorithm and in our capacity of
testing
and also in our turnaround time uh
so this graph here uh shows that uh
our significant parts actually of our
volumes
we run as a set and urgent and
the again the stat testing volumes
is always dependent on the supply chain
and the availability of
asians and i wanted to show this graph
here
uh to just just as a transition on my
projections
for the flu testing in this uh in this
season
um because mainly those two categories
uh
include those symptomatic population and
the volumes
i'm expecting to see um that will
require orders for source
and flu so we can only project um
what will happen this flu season are
based on what we know
uh so we know that so far that both are
flu
and source can cause very similar
symptoms
um clinically maybe there might be some
distinctive criteria
of um that can be unique to either one
for example covered can present with a
change in taste or smell
uh and the development of symptoms after
exposure
may be delayed for up to 14 days
however we would expect
that testing will be needed to
differentiate and confirm a diagnosis
between the two um
so there's a really nice table on the
cdc website
for the differences between clinically
between the two viruses if you are
interested
also we know this season will be
different because
we know that our first virus
is already spreading in the community
significantly
and we are expecting that both viruses
will be circulating
in the fall and in the winter and there
is a possibility of co-infection
uh the extent of which is not yet known
but this is expected
um so based on these expectations um
and based on what happened
when we started um testing for source
back in march
we can just try to expect what will
happen so
when we started testing uh for cover 19
and march
this coincided with the end of the past
flu season
and um um you can see here um
that this is um this is our flu testing
uh here on in the top and uh
when this this distinct distinct period
which is started in march 4 cover 19
uh coincided at that time with the end
of the flu season because we peaked in
january and in february
and we started to decline at that time
however what happened was that um
um the testing for covet in this month
started as an algorithm so the testing
started with flu
and then uh if the patient was positive
for flu
they didn't get tested for source this
was really based on
um uh the idea that uh
source would uh source community spread
was
was minor and it was rare to find and
this this this is really what caused
this peak uh in flu testing
and marsh that you can see on the graph
and
which was even um a little bit higher
than our peak and the flu season
so we are expecting that this will be
different
um this for this flu season
and i'm expecting that um
all the flu orders will be both for flu
and source cov2
uh because now that we know that both
viruses are actually circulating and it
is not um
um maybe even the source the virus might
be
of higher positivity than the flu virus
in the beginning
and and i am expecting that um this will
be ordered for the symptomatic
population
um and that um
this symptomatic population will come
from both um
the stat urgent and routine categories
that i just discussed
uh in this context then um if we have
panels that can uh combine the two
targets
this will be very valuable um so i'm
still
expecting that the extended panels will
be ordered
for our hospitalized patients severely
ill or immunocompromised as i will
discuss in a minute
but still we will need a stand-alone
source assay
for asymptomatic screening and for
certain other situations
so this is the flu testing algorithm
based on the cdc
um and the guidance actually give an
option for
diagnosing the clinically in certain
situations
and also offer guidance on when and
when to offer testing for flu
and this is what we actually do
in a flu season this is our testing
algorithm for flu
we have two different assays that we run
for two different populations of
patients
uh so we run this uh the smaller panel
uh
of from gen expert the sofia uh
for um significantly more patients uh
who are really outpatient
or eddy that are not very sick and
they are not admitted or of no of no
high risk
and we run the extended respiratory
panels um
for inpatients uh or any a severely sick
patient uh in the ed that will be
admitted and also for
immunocompromised patients um
so the question is now um how will uh
the surgical v2 pandemic a change this
testing algorithm
this fall if there is a surge in cover
19 cases which we expect now to happen
based on what is happening nationwide um
are we expecting then to see an increase
in the requirement for the extended
tunnel
which might be then preferred because we
will be expecting
to see an increase in hospitalization or
severely sick patients
and then including the source the target
to our already existing tunnel will then
dramatically improve our workflow
uh so i wanted here to mention that
there are currently
three um uh or at least so this is what
i'm aware about
uh three eua panels that have uh
combined
uh source and flu testing in their panel
um that include the cdc bio fire and
kyogen
um we in the lab as i mentioned um
uh we already have the eplex panels um
and we were thrilled
that they also developed a new panel uh
that
that added source to cov2 test um
and we currently can run under their
pending eua
and we finished evaluating the test and
i will briefly discuss
our experience with this panel um it was
also great
uh i was happy to see that they did this
equivalency studies
um that also showed that um their new
panel
is equivalent to their respiratory panel
one or their
older panels um so this will help us
also to
transfer our already validated sources
to the new panel without the need for
extensive validation
for example we already validated um bals
to use on the panel so we can then just
do a bridging study
and do the same uh and and here uh
it's uh highlighted in the figure are
the targets that co-amplify was the
first
v2 and this includes adenovirus
flu and flu a and flu v
and they conducted those performance
characteristics
um uh to show that uh adding the source
uh target to the assays didn't really
affect the performance and
then all the other targets were not
really changed
um so because um the new panel is really
then
basically a combination of the source
kovi to stand alone test from
from denmark as well as the extended
efflex panels um i will just to briefly
talk about our experience with the two
assays
before i get into the new panel uh so
the e-plex
sarsoco v2 assay was one of the first
essays
that we implemented in the lab this was
along with our
altoona and the cdc assays and
our first studies showed that on the
analytical sensitivity of this assay was
comparable to the
cdc and altona assays um this
study was done mainly by via contrived
rna because at that time we didn't have
access to many
clinical materials to really use for our
validation
and when we did the agreement using the
clinical specimens after we implemented
the estates
this assay the eplex essay for source
um should 100 percent agreement with
altoona
say which we were currently or at that
time it was our main essay running
so in this table this is the positive
agreement but we also had 100
percent agreement on the level of the
negatives which i'm not showing here
um then we did also um an analytical
sensitivity study to try to understand
how all our assays perform
and as a part of this comparison uh we
also tested the genmark
efflex source assay and
the analytical sensitivity using a
quantified material
clinical clinical specimen actually by
digital pcr
showed equivalency and its sensitivity
in comparison with our
other commercial and closed systems
um then uh when we implemented the
extended respiratory panel which we did
um
at the end of 2019 and we started using
this panel now for about seven months
um switching from our older panels um
to the eplex panel significantly
actually improved our turnaround time
from an average of 27 hours to six hours
and i should say
this time is also even better right now
this comparison was done
shortly after implementing the panel uh
where we were actually
still um optimizing our workflow
and also in this table this is our usage
of the panel
and um i'm gonna also show um it here
uh to um our usage of the panel
initially after we went live
um uh was an average of about
1200 to 1300 per month
and after starting to test for first co
v2 or with the source of the pandemic
we noticed that the orders we received
for the
the tunnel went down
and then you can see here also our usage
of the source v2 e-flex efflex test
and and how it started to increase
gradually
between march and june and this was
basically because of the supply chain
from the company
they started to ramp up on their
production lately and
this coincided with this increase and i
should say this has helped
with our testing for the our urgent
category
um now the the source of v2 assay from
the e-flex
um versus the the panel or versus the
extended respiratory panel workflow the
the workflow the the first workflow
included um
uh an initial step that's required
on adding uh the specimen to a sample
delivery
device um and then loading
this uh into the cartridge which is
shown here on the top
uh now they changed their workflow a
little bit to it
to get rid of this step of adding the
specimen
to the to this um sample delivery device
and you can now um through this workflow
we
add the specimen directly to the
cartridge and
they noted that actually the limit of
detection is improved
using this workflow and
the sensitivity is better so
this is better explained in this slide
so you can see that um the workflow
which
starts with um getting your specimen
ready
and then loading the specimen directly
into the cartridge
and loading this directly into the
machine getting rid of these bottom
steps
um that included adding the specimen to
the sample delivery device
and then vertexing and loading into the
cartridge
so the we calculated that the hands-on
time right now
and our average is 29 seconds um i think
uh the first workflow was around one and
a half minutes
so this is by itself it's a little bit
of an improvement
and especially that it's also adding an
enhanced sensitivity
uh so the clinical performance
evaluation
of the e-plex respiratory panel 2
um which included the source kuvi to
target into the extended panel targets
was done now that the company did this
equivalency studies
and they showed that the panel is not
really affected or the targets were not
affected by adding the source target
but this was also confirmed by some
clinical performance evaluation studies
where they tested some samples
um that were mainly in esopharyngeal
swaps
um and um uh the
comparator methods where uh eua approved
essays for the first target
and then the comparator method for the
other
rp2 panel targets was the iplex rp panel
which
is the older extended panel and you can
see here
um in this table um that they here
focused on showing the clinical
performance
of the rp2 targets that co-amplify with
the first
target which as i mentioned include
adenovirus
influenza targets and um uh infill once
and for one the eight targets end in
filonza
b and an equivalent
performance was shown between rb2 panel
and
rp1 tunnels
and also they did a limit of detection
study for the source to cov2 target
and and the sensitivity uh was shown to
be
about 250 genomic copies per ml
this was done by testing about 20
replicas per concentration
um and this was the lowest concentration
that was detected in at least
95 percent um
of the time uh now this is our own data
from hopkins
evaluating the rp2 panel so we did
an agreement to study where we compared
the performance of the rp2 and rp panels
and we tried to test as many targets as
we could
so in this table um we noticed 100
percent agreement
for these targets um
that we have tested and
these targets were frozen or the
specimens were
frozen after diagnosis with
rp1 panels and also we did a small
analytical sensitivity
for the force and flu a b targets
and this was done um using either fresh
or frozen specimens
and we try to span uh the city value
range
of specimens that we get and uh
we we um uh we should we show here that
on the
uh or confirm the uh the analytical
sensitivity that was reported um
per package insert uh if we just back
calculate uh based on the ct
threshold values here that are compared
so i just wanted to touch a little bit
about uh co-infections
and um the value that this might add
as we get into the flu season and as we
start implementing
panels that can also add on the source
target to the other um
viral and bacterial causes of
infection so the presence or absence of
source as we can tell
doesn't really predict that there might
be other
respiratory pathogens that are causing
symptoms
and in most individuals um
that have been symptomatic with covid19
the viral rna and the nasopharyngeal
swab and as was measured by the ct value
as we mentioned can become detected um
especially earlier during the sentence
speaking
and a few days after sentence
but like if we have if we can have the
ability to
or offer methods of diagnosis that can
also
detect other um co-infecting
pathogens this will be very valuable um
early reports from china suggested that
co-infection
with other respiratory pathogens was
rare
but now there are some other studies
that um that is showing different
results
um there might be higher co-infection
rates um however the numbers differed on
was is not really that high yet
so um still more
more closer or closer looks to um
co-infection rates with a source will be
critical
you can see here that um a co-infection
has been detected with rhino and entero
with rsv and also with the other
corona viruses that are the endemic
coronaviruses
so if we use the panel testing um this
can also help in detecting other common
pathogens and
also ensure the detection of
co-infections
and it's to me it's also an advantage
um that the new rp2 panel has added
is that the ability to distinguish
between the four
different seasonal coronaviruses
which is of interest right now uh and
studying that
um or like this is the direction right
now of different
um uh studies uh at least we are
interested here at hopkins and looking
at
um the levels of co-infection and
it will be also of interest to look at
the different seasonal coronaviruses as
we study co-infection
so this brings me to my conclusions here
um so
based on our uh experience here at
hopkins with
starting from the beginning uh of the
source cov2 outbreak or pandemic
this pandemic has really challenged the
diagnostic collapse
and with quick new assays implementation
and we have continuously now faced
con workflow changes um and we have to
deal with this on a daily basis we
expect that this upcoming flu season
will be particularly challenging
and uh we um we don't really have
uh yet a clear idea on uh
what will the order ordering look like
how many
uh are we expecting um however
uh we know that the multiplex um assays
that will combine
uh the source and the flu uh will be
very valuable of course
this will be contingent on a secure
supply chain for agents
so if i go back to our flu testing
algorithm
here in the lab we i'm expecting that we
will see a significant increase
in in both flu testing and source
testing
and i know
i know also that um our
testing on the gen expert
at least through the media release that
they are also there will be an assay
that combines the source flu and rsv
so on both arms of this algorithm i'm
expecting a huge increase in the usage
the workflow will be uh facilitated on
uh if when we when we implement the rp2
panel
uh especially if we think that on the
number of uh six population and
immunocompromised population might
increase
so if we can meet uh the testing
requirement
for both flu and rsv so uh
through rsv and source targets in a one
panel
um uh based on what we can expect
of uh from the uh like numbers of
patients that we are expecting
this will uh um this will really enhance
or
improve our workflow and will help with
um our turn around the time and um
um ease of testing in the lab um
so with this um i would like i have a
huge list of people to think um
and i just would like to give a huge
shout out to the entire
uh clinical microbiology lab here for
all their efforts
um and and this pandemic and in the
response to testing
and enhancing our turnaround time and i
would like to thank
you all for listening and i will take
any questions
thank you dr mustafa for your
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
so let's get started our first question
is
our normal result time is 90 minutes or
excuse me yes our normal result time is
90 minutes
why is the eplex stars kobe 2 test
result time 2
hours uh so the timing the time i put
in here was really the time from the
test order um sorry the specimen
receiving
until the release of the results so i
always put into account
this time in between
but the wrong time i i agree the runtime
is 90 minutes
now if you were to choose the most
reliable test method
best match for the need to monitor
possible outbreak
to monitor infection on a college campus
which would this be
um so this is a very difficult question
so
in this context the optimal method will
be the method that can
run um uh on the best sensitivity
and the and can accept multiple
specimen types and can
also be uh very quick in its turn around
the time
um just because an action should be
taken on the positive results
that include um contact tracing and
infection control
and it should be offered to accommodate
um a larger scale so it can be it should
be it should be offered on a larger
scale
so this this should be the optimal
method
now do you treat pediatric populations
in your emergency department differently
than shown in your flu algorithm
are pediatrics pediatric emergency
department providers
always want a full rp panel
uh so i'm not i'm not really sure
if our pediatric population is treated
differently
um so and and based on our lab
memo um this is the population we uh
suggested that the order the extended
panel for
um so i the the the short star answer is
that i'm i'm not really sure if the
practice for pediatrics differ
so i i believe it doesn't
so dr mustafa our next question what are
the tsar's
kovi targets will be in the rp2
uh i believe it will be the same as the
first essay of eplex which is the n-gene
and now moving on to our next question
what is your preferred
for um for the workflows
um would you be more sorry would you
explain this question
what so
the question that was provided so what
is your prefer for in workflows
um for our guests who did
ask that question feel free um oh here
we got some clarification
uh what is your preferred for the
workflow for the sars kobe 2 test
uh the workflow for source cov2 test as
sto for the whether if it's workflow a
or b
through the eplex assay is this is this
question is the specific for this part
so i think i think then um the workflow
b
is preferred um because it reduced the
hands on time
um it's now uh 29 seconds
um also it got rid of one step um
which we had to load the specimen into
the specimen processing tube
so you are actually eliminating um a
step where
uh which can increase the chance of
contamination and so on you're reducing
the pipetting steps into one step
rather than two steps um and also there
is an
increase in the sensitivity there so i
would prefer b
we've gotten so many good questions from
our audience so we are going to continue
with a couple more
i do want to remind our audience that
the questions we are unable to answer
today and those that come in during the
on demand period
will be answered by dr mustafa or
genmark diagnostics via the email
address we provided at the time of
registration
so our next question we will continue
with why do you think
detecting co-infections with sars kobe 2
will be clinically meaningful for your
institution
so it will be really important to
understand co-infections
um and correlated with outcome studies
uh because this
this is an era which is really um
not very uh well uh visited yet
um so there are multiple
groups that who are already interested
and have been asking me
already for different options for
detecting a co-infection
so if we have this data already
available through our clinical
assay it will be very valuable
and how will the larger panel with the
inclusion of sars kobe 2
relieve burden on the laboratory
workflow this influenza season um
so um if we um if we assume that we
don't
have the source v2 added to the to the
already existing panel
then we will and and based on my
speculation that
a large group of the population tested
for source
will also receive an order for flu um
and and this population of patients whom
for whom we receive the
extended panel requests will also order
a
source test then the timing of
and the workflow will improve by running
two tests instead running one test
instead of two tests
so this will reduce the time to to
result
and it will also give the diagnostic
result
earlier and will also reduce our hands
on time here in the lab
so it will be very valuable from
different perspectives
so our next question are your specimens
received in btm
normal saline or mtm so right now we
receive the specimens in utm
and we receive the specimens as e-swaps
um
and we don't as yet receive saline or
npm
now dr mustafa does the e-plex e-way
cover
different swat types for example nasal
or
only the nasopharyngeal swab type it's
only a nasopharyngeal type
great now what is the utility for you to
have a panel that includes
more than influenza and sars kobe 2
for the upcoming influenza season and
beyond
um so i think this question brings up
again to the co-infection rates
um and to the population of patients
uh where uh uh extending the targets
tested uh is kind of required
which include the immunocompromised and
severe severely sick
uh for also implementing uh
of infection control and so on
especially if the patients will be um
hospitalized and it will be in the
context of source
v2 outbreak especially um important for
also detecting rates of co-infection and
to also understand the better the
outcome
within in different scenarios
now our next question is a two-part
question
do your clinicians request retesting by
a different assay if the first assay
used in your lab comes back
negative and how often does that happen
and
is it on the same or a new specimen uh
we don't we don't usually do that
we already proved that all our assays
are very comparable in their analytical
sensitivity
and uh usually testing which we we did
this in the very beginning
until we were very comfortable in the
fact that if a specimen is negative it's
not
it is not probably due to the analytical
performance of the essay
so we don't currently do that but we are
aware that on
repeat testing is ordered for patients
but it's not it's like it's extended
through different
um like it's consecutive testing of some
some patients which has been a part of
the
new idsa recommendations anyways for
certain population of patients
but this is the only context we get on
repeated testing
on the same patients for uh we don't
test
a same specimen if the physician has a
concern
about an analytical performance uh issue
that we don't
great so what are the different strains
of coronavirus and has the virus
undergone mutation
um so different strains of
the current source cov2 or are we
looking like larger so i have been
a part of um the sequencing um
initiative here at hopkins and we
started to um
look at the strains circulating here and
the area
and the virus i should say the mutation
rate is very very low
um and however there are different
clades um so i
not sure if this answers this this
particular question
not a problem we'll move on to our next
one do any of your physicians request
reporting the ct value with the results
um yes that's that has become a very
common request
um and we don't report the ct values in
our reports
this is at the end of the day a
qualitative essay we run nine different
methods um and uh the they target
different
genes so it will be quite complicated to
uh provide a comp like um
like a city value in this context
also some assays don't report the city
value like
the panther which we also use um but we
have been releasing
them um as um to the to the physicians
in certain situations upon request
and it looks to me that they are
valuable to know
um sometimes uh to understand
um if if really the viral load is
going low um and so on uh and i think
this has been um
um also like reported from like at least
through my conversations with different
labs that it has become a very common
request
now did you find any co-infection of
various flu
in the copa 19 patients
so we so far actually didn't have the
chance to do so here
because um when we started testing flu
went down and we didn't see i think we
only had
two uh at that time back and back in
at the end of march and right now we
don't have
we don't we didn't start seeing flu yet
so i don't have an answer for this
all right so we'll continue on with our
next one uh
they'd like to know if the rapid test or
rt
pcr is a more reliable test method for
the coven 19 detection
um i think the question will be in
comparison to what
uh so so far the molecular methods are
really the gold standard for diagnosis
which
includes rtpcr among others
the most of the available molecular
methods are based on
pcr whether then the detection is real
time
or most of them are real time really
and then there are other methods that
have
shown also comparable performance um uh
so for example the e-plex which we
discussed today
um this is uh this includes an
amplification step
uh but the detection is not through
real-time pcr
and still the analytical performance is
very comparable to real-time pcr
and then there are other methodologies
also that has been added which includes
crispr method
and and so on uh but i think
the uh the proper answer will be on that
molecular methods for detection
are sensitive and so far are the gold
standard
now our next question how does sars v2
attached at the lungs
if you could please elaborate more on
that
if possible in the lungs so i think in
the lungs we
consider this lower respiratory tract
and we would look at lower respiratory
tract specimens
and for molecular methods uh here in the
lab
those will be bronchoalveolar lavage
where you
actually are like trying to wash those
deep as you like
and get the specimen from there or
sputum where um
if the patient actually is producing
sputum so this is also considered a
lower
respiratory specimen type and they can
reflect
on the lower respiratory portion of the
respiratory tract
if we compare this to a swab from the
nose or anesopharyngeal swab
now dr mostafa we did receive a question
saying
my question would be related to expert
integrated test which would be 45
minutes max
according to their announcement would
this be a method of choice for triage
so again it's it's it's based on our
algorithm of testing and
it's usually uh the main bulk of our
testing is done
on this platform because most of the
specimens come from the outpatient
population or the ed
and it will be our um if my
calculations are right um um
we will and flu and source are both
ordered
through our um stat urgent and routine
testing
we are unexpecting that we will receive
about 500
uh requests per day for both flu
um and source that we are expected to
run on gen experts
um so it is the two goal tests and those
population of patients and the extended
panel has its own population of patients
perfect and it looks like we have time
for one more question
so why is it using a low plex panel
like that on the gen expert would still
be crucial when having a more enhanced
panel
like that of the e-plex so it's again
because of what you really need in which
population
and also differences
in the supply chain and how many you can
get for each
um so um in certain population of
patients of the outpatient
on it's necessary to test for source
and for um um for infant ones uh if you
if this will be
important for the management which it is
um and maybe it
is not as um as critical to test for
other targets if you compare this to an
immunocompromised population
where diagnosing another target will be
also essential for
the for managing the patient like para
influenza or any other target
so it's really based on the population
you are looking at
and the situation is is it a
hospitalized patient
where you need to start um your
contact measures and isolation even if
it's a para influenza or another target
this is those are really important in
making the decision on which
which is which test to order
thank you again dr mustafa do you have
any final comments for our audience
uh no i would i just would like to thank
you all again for the invitation and
thank you for listening
and just to stay safe and wear your mask
absolutely so before we go i'd like to
thank the audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions that we did not have time for
today and those submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed
via the contact information that you
provided at the time of registration
we would like to once again thank dr
mustafa for her time today
and her important research we would also
like to thank labbert and our sponsor
genmark diagnostics
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
you can view the webinar on demand and
labyrinths will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
that's all for now until next time
goodbye